everyone comes with this mindset of
curiosity with this mindset of learning
about new things and growing as people
and so that I think has been one of the
most exciting parts of this journey
having a strong Hispanic Student
Association was very important to me
particularly because it's a strong part
of my identity and so I was really glad
of how established that Community was
here on campus Latinos were're not a
monolith right we're multi ethnic or
multi-racial very intersectional and so
we have two organizations here on campus
to support two sides of that lass stands
for Latin American Student Association
and we also have the hbsa which is the
Hispanic business Student Association
both are student associations that
celebrate Latin Heritage among students
one of them is focused on the experience
of students born or raised in the US and
the other one last I'm more focused not
Latin American students who who are
coming from other countries but we do a
lot of stuff together because we have
this shared cultural heritage what
surprised me about the community in
Lassa was how easy it was to fit in
while at the same time standing out
automatically when I heard someone
speaking Spanish on campus he was like
oh you speak Spanish I speak Spanish
like let's be friends and that was super
easy and there were a bunch of other
things like our values or where we were
raised up abroad the fact that our
families are in other countries fact
that we have to apply for Visa all of
those things join us and makes it I
guess similar each of us is pursuing a
different passion each one has their own
career path which I think it's very
unique and allows each and every one of
us to stand out hbsa is a beautiful
organization and so we do a lot of
different kinds of events from career
academics and also culture and community
building and I love it because it's
given me the opportunity to meet some of
my closest friends and I feel like it's
a a sense of home here at the GSB one of
the things I like about Lassa is that we
have events of all types we have social
events to get students to get to know
each other on campus as soon as we get
here we have more business oriented
events where we get to meet Latin
American leaders alumni and people who
make us reflect about our roles in
business and create career aspirations
we put out a bunch of social events to
Foster Community you know get together
and enjoy the things that bonders as
people like music food like dancing toon
and all of these things I think when
you're moving to a different country
you're always wondering to what extent
you'll feel included like you belong to
what extent you'll really connect and
relate to the people that you're going
to meet when you go there and I haven't
found that to be a problem at the GSB in
fact I think people are very intrigued
to hear where you're from what
experience you've had before their
Intrigue to learn about your culture and
celebrate it and that has felt very
special no matter where you come from
there is definitely a place for you here
at the GSB my number one advice for
prospective students is to not shy away
from your story to really Embrace what
makes you you and to honor that through
your application my advice to
prospective students is to go for it
apply you know I think a lot of us hold
ourselves back because we don't see a
lot of a lot of folks who look like us
or have our similar experiences and I
would encourage all Latino admits
applicants to just go for it apply take
your shot you miss 100% of the shots
that you don't take what I'm most proud
of being part of the hbsa leadership is
really cultivating that safe haven that
space where you belong and one where
you're able to bring your full self I
think it's exciting and vibrant to have
so many Latin students here shaping the
future because I think people here are
ambitious in a g way and they're going
to go on and do great things and I'm
happy that a lot of them are Latin
American I think what makes me most
proud is that we celebrate our culture
and we really Embrace who we are as
Latios and we have so much pride of the
work that it took to get here and how
big this achievement is not only for us
but for our
[Music]
families